- Hey Alexa, play I Remember by T Grizzly.
♪ I go where everybody go ♪
♪ Used to carry bottles to the store ♪
- Nice to meet you.
- Such a pleasure.
- Thank you, how are you?
Very good.
Alexa stop.
- How you doing, man?
- Real good.
- Nice, nice, nice, nice.
- Alexa stop.
Hey Alexa, stop.
- Still figuring it out, huh?
- Yeah, Alexa's still
trying to figure it out.
It's cool, right?
- Cool.
So remember we met at K
Swiss event, Dutch Society.
So we had watched that
video August 11, 2016
and that's what kind of
pushed me to kind of go start
what I'm doing, Dutch Society
when we got into the
streets in different cities
and speak to people about hot topics
and so whether it's talking randomly
about social media, abortion, all that,
topics that people have a say on,
agree or disagree.
So we kind of mash it up
and put it on social media
and people can tell us what
they think about real shit.
And from there,
we've managed to grow
from over 25,000 followers
in different kind of socials, Facebook,
Instagram, just under 4,000 now.
But yeah, things are going well.
But what I really want from you
is to kind of show you what we've got
and you just kind of dissect
and let us know what you think of it.
- Sure.
- This is our Instagram
feed, this is the gram.
- This is an idea of what we do.
So ideally just asking people
topical questions on the street
and also speak to social influencers.
- So basically we're
talking about two formats,
we go to the streets, speak
to people about issues
and another format where we
speak to social influencers
within the UK
and they give us their thoughts
and what's happening in the world.
- I've always thought street video
would always, always work.
I'm very hot on it.
I think it always plays.
I'm a big believer in this genre.
The late night shows did it,
I'm a big believer.
I think the bigger question
is what do you want to happen?
That part I understand.
After that, okay, so you grow it,
so you have millions of eyes on it.
Let's go to the next step.
What?
Are you here to be a non
profit social justice thing,
do you want to make a trillion dollars,
do you want to sell tee shirts,
do you want to sell it to news corp?
I think growing it,
I can give you some,
we have limited time here
so I want to give you the most value
and here's how I think about that.
How to grow it,
the best way for you to grow it
is to watch what I do,
not what I say, right?
So that I think I can help you with
by you just paying more close attention
to why I am growing.
Why do I have a Twitch studio?
Why am I trying to go on live more?
All those things.
And you're more than welcome
to ask those questions here.
I think the more important question I have
is what do you want to happen
when it has a million followers?
I assume you want it to be a
profitable business, right?
- [Male] Of course, yeah.
- So that's why I wanted to go there.
So let's go about it a different way.
I think too many people go this route,
I'm gonna spend two years building this
and then I can go to
BMW or Manchester United
or booths and get money
from them to be a sponsor.
You may want to think
about it a different way.
You can get the same money
from those people right now
by showing them that you
can do this kind of content.
And so I think a lot of
people in your position wait
and try to do a business model
that's based on advertising
and I think you can start tomorrow
and build a business based on service.
Watch what I do not what I say.
I didn't first build a media company
even though I had Wine Library TV.
I built an agency
and then I bought a
media company in Pure Wow
and I'm launching one next week
that you guys are gonna read every day
because it's really about us.
I can see it already,
I want to look at it again
but I have a sense that
you know what to do
so you know what I would do,
I would DM small and medium
and big sized businesses
in the UK every day
until the account is blocked
and say, "Hey, we're Das and
we'd like to do this for you
"and we could ask people
"about the issues of
your business like this
"and we could put it on your channels
"and we could put it on our channels."
And they'll be like, "How much is that?"
And you'll be like, "Oh,
it's like 5,000 pounds."
- We've just one that as well.
We've done one big one, we got 13.8
so we've offered them to
do Monday motivation videos
on the streets of London.
So they agreed to--
- More, more and more expensive.
- 100%
'cause also one thing as well.
- [Female] It has no
relevance to me and my life.
- [Male] For me, it's kind of
celebration of our country.
- [Male] It is important.
It's not something that
I'm gonna go out of my way
to go see but I think it's important
for our country to kind of get behind it.
- [Male] Unless they're
actively doing something
for the country, I really don't care.
- [Female] Who knew that
there would be some sort
of black individual, some diversity
is going to be now incorporated
into the royal family
which is so--
- [Male] Having color
is really interesting
and having color in politics and culture,
but the royal family,
there's an alternative
to the royal family.
- [Female] It makes it relatable.
When you look at them,
when the work is about to happen
you're gonna look at her and think,
okay, there's someone like me
who could be in a situation like that,
it makes it relatable.
- [Female] Getting someone
like me in the royal family.
- [Male] What I say is
she's marrying into a family
that's also slavery.
- [Male] We've all seen Get Out.
There's gonna be a whole
Get Out scenario, I think.
- 100%.
- Our biggest video is
like 2.5 million views
which is on Facebook
and it was on slavery in Libya
and also (mumbles)
which is a big thing
that happened in the UK.
- The biggest thing I would
tell you that you should do,
so back to spitting it,
I think you're getting caught.
I think you're going too heavy.
- In what sense?
- Topic wise?
- I think you're going too heavy.
I think all of the content
is in your direction.
I think about supply and demand.
I think this stuff is heavy
and I think everybody's
getting sucked into heavy
'cause there's negativity in the system.
If I were you,
so if I became the third,
I was like, hey guys, I want
to be the third partner.
You're like, holy shit,
Gary Vee wants to be our third partner.
You'd be like, alright,
Gary Vee, what should we do?
The number one thing I would do
based on what I'm seeing here
is even some of the stuff
that's lighter weight
has deeper meaning.
Bombing Syria, heavy, period, heavy.
Plus size models,
not as heavy as bombing Syria
but we're still talking heavy shit.
Vegans, you can still make,
everything here has political undertone.
I think you guys subconsciously
think that's smart
because it gets polarizing reactions.
I think it's not smart as you think
because everybody's doing it
and there's fatigue in the system.
Let me give you an example.
If every third one here was Coke or Pepsi,
Man U or Man City,
your media company would be much better.
- Makes sense, and all of
them they'll jump like that.
- You're heavy and you need
to give people an appetizer
before the main meal.
- Okay.
So every third one, we
can go back to deep.
- No, I think, you heard what I said,
I think you need to mix
high and low at all times.
- It's too heavy, yeah.
'Cause even right now,
if you look at our thing,
we're getting 100 plus
comments on Instagram like easy
engaging people
like you said, it attracts that kind of--
- It's great other than I think
you could get pay dirt by,
look, you're doing all the right things
like you're screenshots are so on point.
- The screenshots make
sense but the meme borders--
- The meme borders are commoditized,
the people you're putting in the pictures
are exactly right.
Here's the pretty girls,
here's the clearly Israeli dude.
You guys are giving good thought.
So I think you're doing
a lot of things right.
I think you're doing
one macro thing wrong.
I think you need to,
my opinion, I think
you're going down a path,
everybody is going down the negative.
You know what's sad right now?
People view this as negative.
This is thoughtful conversation,
I wouldn't argue that it's negative,
I don't think it's negative,
I think they think it's
negative and it gets heavy
and I think you have to try.
I don't think I'm right.
I think you have to see
if there's any right in where I'm going.
I think it's a clever thing,
that would be my first observation.
- And what do you think,
going straight into that,
Man United, Red Bull--
- I think the other thing is
you have to use more hashtags.
- More hashtags.
- Oh, you're using them on
the first post, okay, good.
Nope, I'm okay with it.
- [Male] So obsessed about
what other people do.
- The other thing I would do
is I would transcribe it.
You're not transcribing it.
- We've just done that,
our first video on Facebook last week,
that's the first time,
it just makes sense.
(cross talk)
- [Male] People are gonna get
offended by it and that's fine
but I don't think that that
should stop you from saying,
people should still say the F word
and everything like that.
I don't think the racial
history of the N word
should stop it being the F word.
I think the more people say it
and the more that we let
other ethnic groups say it
and same things like the P word,
than all these racial slurs,
the more they lose their power
'cause I let all my white
friends say the N word
and he's like, "You shouldn't do that."
I'm like, no, because if we keep
stopping them from saying it--
- He's actually right in my opinion
but it's so hard to go there.
I laugh so hard when I sing music
and I will not say it.
- Even my black friends won't.
- But you know what's funny,
but back to black friends,
in college, my friends
wanted me to to his point.
You're never worried about,
I'm never worried about
what D Rock thinks of me
'cause he knows all my truths.
You never want somebody
to think you're doing the
wrong thing if you can help it.
- So stuff like that--
- But again, it's interesting,
even when you guys try to,
it's just where you guys are at,
even when you try to
do it a little lighter,
it's got a negative,
why do you think I'm probably doing well?
I'm by default optimistic,
my video would've been
biggest opportunity.
It's the same thing.
You see where I'm going?
I feel like for example,
here's a good one,
let's talk about kind of heavy topics,
the thing that I've been
spending a lot of time on,
I just can't stop thinking about it
which is I go on Breakfast Club
as a 42 year old wealthy white man
and the things that are
coming out of my mouth
are nobody gives a fuck
which is like if you read it on paper,
you would be like,
this guy's gonna get
murdered by the culture.
But it's the reverse
'cause it's coming from a good place.
I'm not saying nobody gives a fuck
because I think I'm better than you
or I don't like you,
it's that I know that the
second you actually realize that
then you can start
because if you're holding on,
it doesn't mean I downplay the truth.
You know what I mean?
It's just like I have truths too,
everybody's got truths.
I always bring up the
super white rich person,
they're fucked up more.
Their truth is nobody in this room,
I don't know you guys
but just the color of
your skin and I know us,
nobody's gonna feel bad
for $25 million trust fund baby, Tyler
but guess what,
if that person happens
to also be ambitious
and wants to have a
reputation for himself,
he's finished.
Us four can get out of
our situation and win.
He can't.
No matter what he accomplishes,
they'll be like, I guess he can,
actually he can do something,
just give it all away and start at zero
and that's probably what he has to do.
So anyway, that is
super interesting to me.
I think you need to,
because I think the nature
of banter and points of view
is far more powerful,
for example, I think that I'm gonna help
entrepreneurs and people a lot more,
I think I almost use my
personality and my optimism
as a trick to get people
to do the right thing.
I'm gonna get a lot more
with honey than vinegar.
I think if you guys mixed
in some lightweight shit,
your other hard hitting
shit will land better.
I look at that,
and I can see a lot of people,
like this is agenda driven.
See where I'm going?
I think Man U, Man City is real.
You've got World Cup
coming up, nice and light,
still has things in it,
see where I'm going?
I don't know the London market well
but the crow nut was this
big craze in Manhattan,
I'm sure there's some food or
restaurant right now popping
that everyone wants to talk about
or Pusha, Drake.
I think you guys have permission for that.
See where I'm going?
I think one out of every three or four,
one out of every five even if you want to,
I don't want to deviate
you from your mission,
but I will tell you,
the thing that things like this do wrong
is yeah, yeah, yeah and
then you're just like,
alright, I've been eating this heavy meal,
you've got to have salad sometimes,
you've got to have a
cupcake once in awhile.
You want to get people to eat healthy?
Don't make them 100% vegan.
Make it okay to eat a fucking something,
not that that's the point
but you see where I'm going?
I feel like I've figured out my weight
'cause I don't beat myself
up if I have one bad day.
I've been on point,
okay yeah, I want to get
tighter a little bit right now
but one bad day,
on the flight out,
I've been getting my shit
together a little bit, tighter,
but I didn't have a good
day on the flight here
'cause I was trying to fall
asleep and wine and food,
I'm just trying to go to sleep.
If I just kept beating myself up,
I'd be four days
but yesterday I fasted easy
and had a couple things I picked at.
It's a very important thing
and that's the thing
that's happening here,
it's like boom, boom, boom
and if you're really into it,
you love it until you don't
but you're making it a very narrow thing.
It's so funny, that makes me laugh
'cause I believe in this so much,
I want to do so much of this.
I want to do it a lot,
we're actually gonna do
some stuff like this,
it'll be like, man on
the street, two minutes,
man on the street is fucking good shit.
Listen, brother, blowing
something up is just patience.
Here's why,
you never know,
here's why I like Man U, Man City,
do you know how many people
aren't gonna fuck with this
content 'cause it's heavy?
Eight out of 10.
Because right now everyone's like,
enough of getting into political debates.
And all you need is one Man
U player to give it love.
Telling you right now,
optimism and light and happy
and smiles wins the day.
Now, look at me,
I'm that, I don't shy
away from heavy stuff,
I talk about suicide,
but when you're just one,
or the other way, I don't dodge
and I'm not just like,
no, it's all rainbows,
I go, you guys know my content.
You never really know
exactly what's gonna happen.
It might be heavy, it might not
but I think that's where
you can get more virality.
It may be Syria bombing
because BBC does something
or somebody else or whatever,
the fucking Prince
thinks it's a good piece of content, sure,
but it could also be
cheeseburgers or chicken wings.
And I think you should give
yourself a little bit of room.
And I think you should
DM microinfluencers.
- [Male] How micro?
- I would say 10 to 20,000
and be like, we just like your stuff
and we'd love to have you
as one of the opinion people
in here.
So when you make them,
you have, I wouldn't even make
any acknowledge to it either,
instead of making them the default,
first of all, they're gonna tag it
and second of all, it's
just like an Easter egg,
you give people a reason to watch.
You never know when Nigel
Thompson shows up for no reason.
See where I'm going?
It's a wink.
You can't imagine how
much shit we're doing,
let me rephrase, he doesn't even know,
I do so many little Easter
eggs to, not even D Rock,
I'm doing it for myself or to my team.
So I'll give you a preview,
it's literally gonna be announced ASAP,
so the new men's which is
like complex meets VICE
meets Forbes meets Gary Vee,
it's gonna be called 1:37
PM, that's gonna be my site
and I'm gonna hope you watch it every day
and we're doing some cool shit,
interviewing people, content,
we just put out a shirt
that I sold and empathy is a superpower,
it's like a comic book
and in there it says five cents
which is my favorite number five
but it also says volume 137.
Nobody knows why that's there but now,
I love that kind of shit
and people love that kind of shit.
People oh!
When wait a minute in that
first movie in this trilogy
they actually made a head
nod to what just played out.
Fuck!
And that's what I'm doing.
I'm doing all sorts of little things
that like I can point to
episode 12 and you'll be like,
oh, it's gonna be like,
oh, he's been thinking about this.
This isn't luck.
Pleasure.
- Thanks a lot.
Few days ago I saw you.
- Oh there we go, I'm excited.
I love that, here we go.
Yes, yes, yes.
Oh my God, I'm so pumped right now.
I love it.
I'm literally gonna wear this,
literally gonna wear this.
I can't wait.
I'm gonna have every team,
Vaynerchuk Five jersey
of every fucking team
before this is all done.
- Few days ago, to my boy a new shirt,
I couldn't have that.
- The debate is on, what
is going to be the squad?
We'll see.
I love it, that's amazing.
D Rock, you have to, have to,
have to make sure I get that.
(upbeat music)
♪ I remember being broke ♪
♪ I know before this money go ♪
♪ I'm gonna look up where everybody go ♪
♪ I remember slipping on the ♪